[Music]
this is Star Talk special edition Neil
degrass Tyson here your personal
astrophysicist and with special edition
we explore the human condition as it is
bolstered or interfered with by emergent
technology and who and what we are as a
species and our relationship to Machines
man you made this show sound important
wow
man that was I didn't even I didn't even
know we were doing all of that that chck
nice
Che standup comedian actor still acting
like a comedian acting like a comedian
yes all right and Gary expr footballer
and broadcaster got a interesting show
today we do yeah you put you put
together a show I didn't even know was
possible in our repertoire tell us about
it we found someone who we are going to
orbit around who has made this possible
because about 25 years ago a farmer yes
a farmer decided that he no longer
wanted to be part of industrialized
farming so he threw away the pesticides
threw away the hormones and started to
listen to Mother Nature he is a soil
scientist a hydrologist a biologist a
chemist a nutritionist a weather expert
and a community leader something very
very important he now operates one of
the largest part pure rage livestock
operations in the USA and was the first
outfit to sell a pound of grass-fed beef
to Whole Foods what he yes he calls
himself radically traditional we're just
going to be calling him will Harris will
welcome to Star talk thank you very much
I appreciate you having me it's an honor
oh my gosh you are a fourth generation
farmer will I can honestly say I can
probably count on one hand how many
farmers I've ever met in my life and
you've been a farmer for four
generations and and your how old is your
farm that you work that you're working
on my great-grandfather came to this
Farm in
1866 and we've been farming ever since
and uh and the name of your farm White
Oak
pastures we might have seen that on some
food I I shop at Whole Foods you know I
you know look at you Mr fancy maybe I
gave you some of my
money that was then but they thrown me
out now so they they we we got to find
out about that we're gonna find we're
gonna get into that find out what
happened there uh you're the author of a
bold return to giving a damn that's a
great title that's awesome right right
and that just came out in the fall of
2023 that explores the link between and
among food health and climate change oh
my gosh okay so let me let me start off
by asking you will why would you move
away from industrial farming I presume
industrial farming made everybody make
much more money faster and it allows us
to grow more food on less land with
fewer people than ever before so why
would you ever walk away from
that the short answer is unintended
consequences H everything that you said
is
true more food less land uh probably
more profit but there are unintended
consequences and the unintended
consequences have fallen on the backs of
the
animals the land the environment and the
rural
economy so these unintended consequences
normally when people say that that's a
bad thing I mean because unintended
consequences just means something
happened that you didn't foresee that
can be something good so what what is
the
bad the I mean the former not the latter
is the there a bad thing okay okay and
the the bad things would be the the
impact on the environment you know to to
to operate a modern uh Farm there are a
lot of products used the name end of the
name is side C I D oh that's Latin for
kill yeah like homicide suicide that's
what you mean that's the side homicide
incde pesticide okay
herbicide and I uh I was my father took
over the farm in 1946 and turned it into
a modern industrial linear farming
operation I followed him and never
wanted to do anything except what he did
I went to the University of Georgia when
I came of age I graduated in 1976 we
would degree in animal science and
learned a lot about how to kill pests
and I came home and and implemented
those
teachings successfully financially so
these would be insects but also I guess
weeds too these are both of those you
don't want on your farm anything you
don't want that could be pathogens it
could be insects it could be weeds it
could be so so many things whatever you
there's a product out there to so you
want a don't want a side that's
what allpurpose thing for everything you
don't want that's what you you want a
side in okay yeah but that's not the way
it works but
yeah you're right I gotta tell you Neil
if Dow Chemical comes out with don't
want tode I'll know that they're
listening to this show okay so so will
how long did it take once you made the
changes once the you decided you know
what that's it taking the chemicals out
I'm going to let this mother nature
project take how long does it take for a
reset for you to now make something
positive happen out of this action
that's a great question and when you
make the decision to cease to use all
those Technologies you take a production
hit immediately and it takes a period of
time to overcome it if you made me say a
period of time I would say five years
but I I don't I don't know that's
exactly right it's gradual the things
that you can do to accelerate it uh and
to the to to be honest you never get
back up to the level of maximum
production you had when you were using
all the
Technologies you uh you don't create the
unintended consequences you don't kill
the uh flora and FAA in the Gulf of
Mexico some other favorable things that
you don't do but no one is ever claim to
my knowledge that you maximize
production on the land by giving up the
Technologies you don't you uh but what
you do is you restart the cycles of
nature the the cycles of nature yield an
abundance the cycles of nature would be
for instance the the energy cycle the
water cycle the mineral cycle the
microbial cycle on and on when those
Cycles are operating optimally as they
do in nature they produce an abundance
all that oil and coal and gas in the
ground right is is the abundance of
nature when it was operating
optimally and we've been using that up
since so what we did is uh cease to use
the sides that that end lives and and
work to uh generate the abundance that
comes from all the Cycles operating as
optimally as we can
make but that makes you the the weird
farmer among Farmers right what why why
even go there what what motivated you
did you watch some documentary one night
and said oh my gosh I've been wrong
because it sounds like uh it sounds like
you were working against your own
interest by making this decision right
exactly and did you have like a come to
Jesus moment on this one and you say I
got to change you know the the sad truth
is I probably came to see the damage I
was creating because I was a bit of an
abuser you know I was a very
heavy-handed farmer and if the label
instruction said to use a paint I might
use a quart if it's said to use two CC's
I might use three
CC's so when you
uh
overuse the tools you see the damage the
tools cause and that's what happened to
me and I simply didn't like it and when
I started moving away from it I was not
moving necessarily to this model that we
Embrace today I was just moving away
from that one and this is where it led
me and I'm I'm very pleased that it did
okay when when you say about the health
of soil and things like that what you
have you got to the point where we were
kind of getting is it this
desertification of the soil where it
just just is just dirt and I think that
most of the land that's industrially
farmed today is desertify or has been
desertified and the example I'll give
you is uh organic matter the carbon uh
percentage of of the
soil uh in my land had gotten down to 1
half of 1% oranic
M after 20 years of farming it in
accordance with nature it's 5% organic
mod that's 10x and let me tell you what
that means 1% of organic matter will AB
in soil will Absol a one in Rain of vent
that's 27,000 gallons of water per acre
so my land at 5% will absorb a 5 in
train event and we get them in
Georgia when it was a half a per organic
model it was only going to absorb a half
an inch of rain I don't care how much it
fell that's
terrible and organic m is not the only
thing that's important the
microbial component a lot of things are
important but that's just the easiest
one to State the case for what about
animal welfare because you raise
cattle you know you you've got a a field
to Fork process that we'll get into I'm
sure um so how how long did it take for
you to see the benefits in the animals
themselves that was much easier so
Animal Welfare as an industrial
Cattleman had come to mean you keep them
well fed you keep them well watered you
keep them on comfortable temperature
range you don't intentionally inflict
pain or suffering and that's good good
Animal Welfare that is the accepted
standard and I did that and I thought I
was I thought I was really good at that
I thought my Animal Welfare was above
approach after I had the change of
heart I came to realize that in addition
to those things good Animal Welfare also
means you give the animal the
opportunity to express instinctive
Behavior H C cattle Were Meant to ruin
and graze that's right doogs Were Meant
to root and wallow chickens Were Meant
to scratch and Peck and the industrial
model the way we we do it today
industrially does not allow those
instinctive
behaviors so we start going against
nature yes sir they're going against
nature and you
know you could you could go against
nature raising your children you could
walk them in a closet I do it all the
time and nobody will abduct them they
won't fall off the bike they won't get
tackled on the in run you know it's it's
a good safe place to raise them it's
probably not it's probably not the best
rearing your children can have and
that's what industrial I know production
is is mon cultural
confinment production so let me ask you
a question this is uh slightly off of
what we're where we are right now but
since you brought it up about animal
welfare and
grazing um I was do on a shoot in Dallas
not Dallas it was outside of Dallas but
it was a cattle farm and the cattle were
grazing they had two parts of this farm
and the gentleman who was my Lia on I
was like oh look at that so that's
that's your grassfed and he was like
yeah and I was like I like that I like
grass-fed um and he went you know I'm
not a grass-fed person because I feel as
though it doesn't give you the same type
of fat content that a cornfed c uh cow
would have and so you end up with a
different Taste of the beef I'm I'm a
cornfed person it it does it really come
down to that does it make that much of a
difference that you're going to get a
different product at the very end uh if
something and and the way the way he put
it they're their world apart now I
wouldn't know but what that gentleman
told you was absolutely true and
accurate it's exactly the way it is but
I'll put a little different slant on it
for you okay a grain fed animal that's
butchered typically will be
about well probably less than two years
of age it'll probably weigh 13 or 14400
PBS you probably have at least a half an
inch of back fat and it would be just
just just cut cut down it would be an
unnaturally obese creature that would
never survive in nature and if it were
left in that environment that that may
it so obese it would not live a normal
lifespan wow in fact it probably
wouldn't live I'm just going to guess a
half a natural lifespan wow now is the
Bee from that cow
tender and
juicy
yes is it is the weight put on at a very
competitive
cost
yes but I'm of the opinion that even a
creature that is unnaturally obese and
dying from the uh conditions of
sedentary lifestyle and obesity probably
ain't good for
you you know when you put it that way it
makes sense I mean basically you're
you're eating the cow that sits on the
couch watches TV and eats potato chips
that's what you're
doing exactly no no that is exactly
that's beer yeah okay my cow my cow are
athletes they simply are athletes and
the life the life expectancy of a
cow I think he's 24 years of age I think
that's what I I saw is the normal life
expectancy we don't we don't look let
them live that long but I think that's
what it is and I have every reason to
believe that my animals would live to be
20 24 years old if I just left them out
there where they are right now but I'm
sure they wouldn't live through 24 years
old in that environment that feed lot
environment that we just
discussed you mentioned the term earlier
um linear linear farming the
industrialized farming and we've
discussed soil well-being water content
quality Animal Welfare but you're based
in one of the poorest rural counties in
the
USA what impact was linear
industrialized farming having on the
people not just the soil and the
ecosystems well moving to the linear
model is what has impoverished Rural
America
America we move uh you know Rural
America has continued to be where we
produce the raw material that most food
is made from today we do not add the
value here
anymore we we produce the cattle or pigs
or beets or cotton or corn or whatever
and it is moved in a very linear manner
to another the production some to
another to another where their value is
added and that has impoverished Rural
America because all the value is not
earned where the farm is correct almost
fact very a very small percentage I
think that the last number I saw is that
something like 15 cents of the food
dollar goes to the
farmer so the rest of it goes to someone
else now I'm not saying those people are
getting money without deserving it no of
course not they they add value but it's
impoverishing Rural America so why why
then in in your opinion is the food that
is produced by big agriculture big food
if if you want to call it and tag it
that why is why is the food that we're
consuming so messed up if there's a way
to make it happen differently mean why
doesn't everyone do what will does yeah
that's what you're asking it's a great
question and it's because because the
consumer has wanted cheaper and cheaper
food aggressively demanded cheaper and
cheaper food at least since World War II
and and we provided it we being the the
farmer and the and all the way up the
chain we
provided cheap food in fact I would say
we we
provided obscenely cheap food that was
that has become just wasteful
abundant and it shouldn't be so cheap
how much is that is related to the
explosion of retail eating in this
country so you know you're McDonald's
your Burger Kings you're this and that
the all these restaurants I mean when
you look at it the main stay of all
these restaurants is
beef so I mean how much does that have
to do with it well I think that the the
retail Food business that you
referenced was one more step of taking
cost out of
production taking cost out of food uh
provision you know if uh the fact is uh
McDonald's can buy beef and cook it and
serve it cheaper than you you can buy
beef and cook it in your apartment or
house it's just as simple as that they
they the numbers are so big that tips
the scales and it there's no going back
from that there may be no going back uh
uh you know I hope we can we can some
extent go back you know the uh I think
that there is a segment of our
population that has figured out that
cheap food really isn't that
cheap uh I don't talk too much about the
impact on health I mean I believe that
is one but I'm a farmer not a doctor not
a dietitian and I don't want to get in
that debate there are others that can do
that for me but when it comes to the
impact on the
land I know that industrially produced
food is really really bad when it comes
to the impact on the animals I know that
industrially produced food is really
really bad when it comes to the impact
on local rural economies I know that
that industrial food is really really
really
bad and I don't know of any reason to do
it other than it's cheap it is really
really cheap is it sustainable as a
model to to continue industrialized
farming and just keep making cheap food
and piling it high and whether you eat
it or or it goes to waste is it a
sustainable model I don't believe I'm
convinced that it's not you that is a
source of great debate among on the
people like me as versus big food big
Tech big a but I don't believe that it
is I believe that we are exhausting
Irreplaceable resources and that it will
end poorly and I don't know how but
suppose I mean I'm a fan of Science and
Technology and every time something
turns wrong on it some Innovative clever
person comes up with a solution to it so
if you went down the list of everything
that was wrong with big farmer and
somehow you magically could correct it
then big farmer might be okay right if
they were magic I
don't okay all right you you you've
tagged your your way of farming as field
to fork and I think we can all visualize
exactly how that works but what does
that entail because it's there's all
these this to all now be connected as
opposed to these individual silos that
industrial farming has where someone
takes hold of this and someone takes
hold of that and someone takes out of
the other so how does that entail filter
fork for you and that and that is that's
a great question and that's where it it
becomes most difficult uh the when we my
my dad's generation and later mine
turned food production into something
very linear they they set it up for
scale to have huge plants and factories
producing food taking raw materials in
at a very minimum quality standard and
and fur F further processing it so it
became a marketable product uh that
simply does not work well uh in this
model that we have it is it is not uh
linear therefore it doesn't uh blow up
as well Escala in terms of numbers but
it does replicate in terms of numbers we
we believe that there should be uh food
production in every County every
agricultural kind in the country and a
benefit we hadn't talked about of that
is during the pandemic panic when the
food was gone off the food
shelves and the big meat plants not only
the underwear and the water I mean the
the the toilet paper the toilet paper
and the water
went just as fast bicycles you couldn't
get a bicycle if if you're ra if you're
raing those you know the food is is
pretty close to the top with the with
the toilet paper
Ian close very closely related
very well but during that time uh meat
plants ceased to operate and course I
was I I lived in fear than mine would
too but we never missed a day we never
missed a day operating our red meat
plant and our polter plant here on this
Farm that's because our model is not
nearly as
scalable as the industrial but is far
more
replicatable endurable you've you've
been in the farming business for quite
some time we've established that uh your
historic
traditional all right climate change
does it affect you and how you farm um
or is it you know what their cattle
their leak grass I'll let them they can
wander around be happy or are you both
ways does he affect climate change does
CL climate change affect you both I
think that I think what we do impacts
climate change I think that when I was
farming industrially and buying
thousands of tons of chemical nitrogen
per year and releasing it and
oxidizing God knows how much carbon in
the
soil I was contributing to climate
change I know that what I'm doing now is
a benefit to mitigate against climate
change I mentioned the fact that the
organic matter in my
soil so I think it works both ways yeah
not to mention um in addition to climate
change from an environmental standpoint
you know big Agro farming just the
runoff alone because of the chemicals
that are used is extremely deleterious
to surrounding communities leads to
health problems uh damages uh
waterways contaminates groundwater and
some Carl San said air molecules and
water molecules don't carry passports
that's right pass right across borders
then then that's right I'm about 80 my
farm where I'm sitting right now is
about 80 miles north of the Gulf of
Mexico and there is a dead zone in the
Gulf of me Mexico it's about the same
size as
Massachusetts and when I was a kid when
I was a kid the
oysterman literally brought oysters to
blakele Georgia 10 miles that way once a
week we had fresh oysters they bannned
uh oystering in the Gulf of Mexico now
except for some cultured stuff they do
terrible the the impact on the the
impact that industrial agriculture has
had on the environment is not
arguable it's not arguable you know
there is a study on my website White Oak
pastors.com called an LCA life cycle
assessment it was an 80 something, 80
something, stud that a customer paid to
have done on my farm by a thirdparty
environmental engineering firm from
Chicago I
think and they came here to see what we
were doing and the expectation was that
we were contributing
to carbon depletion in the soil and all
those other things but what they found
is that our cataly
operation actually
sequesters 3 and2 pounds Listen to Me 3
and2 pound of carbon for every pound of
beef we
produce that's and that's not magic no
it's not magic it's nature it's nature
and you know I could argue that Nature's
a little bit magic but it's
nature oh we talk about nature and uh I
said earlier on in the show that
you started to listen to Mother Nature
and if I remember rightly you say that
Mother Nature will provide everything
you
need to be successful in farming now
that's easy to say but how do you get to
a conclusion like that plus nature
there's a lot of poisonous stuff that'll
kill you outright in nature right so
nature doesn't always equal good and
non- nature doesn't always equal bad so
do you tread that line
well I'm not sure that nature doesn't
always equal good it doesn't always
equal life yeah
you yes there's stuff out there that
will kill you and there's stuff out
there that will make you strong you
should eat what makes you strong you
should not eat what will kill
you one way or the other you'll figure
it out one
way oh no I was going to say hopefully
somebody will figure it out for you that
yes
the when the guy beside you eats that
green thing right and falls over you
don't need to eat that green thing there
you
go so will tell me about this book you
just released a bold return to giving a
damn and I
it's the future matters to us all in so
many ways and everyone thinks they have
the answer and people are fighting over
who has the best answer or who moving
fast enough or not fast at all where
does your book land in this or where
where where are you taking the reader in
your attempt to show the world through
the lens that you have so hard-earned in
your life so the book the book is about
my 25 years of returning this form from
a very industrial monocultural cattle
production operation to a very what I
believe is a very uh Perpetual sort of
farming
operation that that that feeds us and
does so then one a am that is Humane to
the animals and improves not that not
degrades the landscape agriculture 2.0
is what you're talking about here this's
a new a new mindset or maybe maybe 3.0
because 1.0 was Farmers before there was
technology then there was Tech
technology and now you're kind of going
back back back to Roots here I think
it's I think it's
3.0 yeah that we
uh you know my family has been on this
farm for 160 or whatever years and we
farmed the way that in a man that's
similar to what I farm today but we have
forgotten it let me say this I am not
anti-technology you know we've got uh
I'm on my fourth
drone B
okay A a drone is just an a flying thing
that has cameras and other stuff right
ceras is what we use and we use them
every I use that as an example we got
you know we've got a lot of Technology
here and I embrace it and I use it and I
play it we Gap so you're not
anti-science and Technology you just God
the application I'm I'm trying to use it
in a manner that that does
not detract from the the natural flow of
things so we because if if you if Nature
has a natural flow and then you try to
go against it what are the consequences
they're
bad we're do I mean you got to be more
specific but we're doing it right no I
no okay almost everything we call
civilization has has been a push back
against nature right we build a city on
the waterers Edge and then yeah storm
comes in every now and then there's a
flood Nature's fighting back but no we
won that fight we build a dam to create
electricity and fresh water that's a
fight we win against we've fought a lot
of battles against nature and won in the
service of civilization but there's
always the consequences of that of that
battle that you're talking about in that
Dam you often end end up killing the
wildlife that uses that Waterway or you
have to make some type of concession for
instance I'm thinking salmon
particularly you have to make a
concession for that particular water
Wildlife you know when it comes to
storms if you don't have marsh land
surrounding that City that City will
flood and the storms will destroy the
city so the fight has to have
concessions that allow you to has to be
intelligent intelligently done
intelligent
yes these are unintended consequences
the unintended consequences can be uh
devastating and I don't know I don't I
don't you know I'm not the guy that's
smart enough to know which ones of these
ideas are good ideas and which ones are
bad ideas but I do know because
firsthand I witnessed it on this Farm of
the degradation that came from using
these Technologies to kill something
again we get back that deal by side
when I was an industrial cat
monocultural industrial Cat every single
day I went in my pasture and looked
aggressively for something to kill wow
pathogen a weed species an insect on and
on so let me ask you this because this
is fascinating to I I can't believe we
didn't get to this earlier what did you
replace that with Coca if you're using
something with a side on it okay just to
stop using it you still can have
invasive whether it's a pathogen whether
it's a pest itself or you know whether
it just is another species of plant that
you don't want coming into to your crops
H what did you replace that with you're
exactly right and and it there will be
another pest that results from the use
of that side and there's a side for it
too aha it's the endless
constant use of killing something my
goal when I was an industrial
monocultural every day was to kill
what displeased me
now my goal is to make these things live
because every single species out there
has a role in that natural environment
how do you get rid of the weeds then how
do you get rid of the parasites that
they eating the food you're trying to
grow and sell how do you do that without
the magic of modern met modern chemicals
the same way the same way that had
happened for thousands of years you know
I I ceased to have the monoculture of
cattle because the weeds were eating me
up and I got sheep and goats and Hogs
and poultry and they they they hi it now
my pastures are not pristine when I was
farming Industrial
and monoculture with cattle it was a mon
my passage were a monoculture of Tifton
85 Bermuda grass that that was bred by
the University of Georgia and it will
assimilate incredible amounts of
chemical nitrogen and turn it into
forage for cattle it's
incredible but the use of that level
of nitrate fertilizer
uh
literally destroyed the organic mod and
oxidized is word oxidized the organic
matter in my
so and I had the other other species
would appear and I would spray it uh
with gry Zone pnd
herbicide and the army worms would eat
it up so I would spray that then would
late and then the list goes on and on oh
yeah okay okay yeah so so if you're you
successful in the context of your
mission statement have has this caught
on to other
farming communities other counties other
I mean ideally that's that's what you'd
want right it is what I wanted and and
sadly it has not C on I don't mean I'm
the only one doing it I don't mean that
but it is not C on because primarily
because of competition from Big
multinational corporations right
chines but consumers are not without
power here so if people wanted to get
you know they read your book and they
say we are all in on this what do we do
as consumers just be very picky about
what we buy as an endpoint in the
production cycle you're right the
consumer will determine how this all all
goes down how this proceeds forward and
if they decide to find Farmers like me
and to support them there would be more
Farmers like me for them to support and
it can grow because that's how that goes
yeah so we as a consumer we need to
adopt a local farmer is this what we're
thinking in the sense of not not to give
them a home but to support
them you know by buying their produce
you're you're you're exactly right and
and I I I got to say that because we
white Pastor started very
early I'm selling as much product as I
want to sell I'm I'm fine I'm not trying
to grow this business business but I'm
selling it in 48 states and that was not
my plan oh wow you know I I can't sell
as much product as I need to sell in
bluon Georgia with a population of 120
people but Georgia Florida Alabama and I
want other people to do it in other
places and I had hoped that would be the
case but the
multinational food companies
have seen the uh uh acceptance of some
of this messaging that people like me
are are putting out yeah and so they
greenwash their product and greenwashed
product is the Nemesis of this kind of
farming goinging how are they
greenwashing will uh well I mentioned
earlier you can bring grassed beef in
from 30
countries and label it as a product of
the USA legally it's
the animal is grown
slaughtered processed packaged in
Uruguay New Zealand
Australia 20 something other countries
but then it's it
legally and that that that got changed
in
[Music]
2015 you couldn't do that but you can
lab it product of the USA because value
was added in this country right and it
oh that's how that works yeah that's how
it works and it was a game changer and
it was wrong and it was done because
multinational corporations have so much
power damn so I mean the way around that
direct to Consumer sales is is that a is
that a is that something that needs to
really be and and education I think what
what education is a big thing where it
is catching on and um we've all seen
this especially here in the New York
area is Farm totable rest resturants
where the restaurant owners are making
the decision to Source Products from
local farms so that they can have a
better product on their restaurant table
farm to table farm to table far to table
so you know it is catching on in some
respects if the needle is moved on the
way we produce food in this country it's
going to have to be done by the consumer
yes it's not going it's not going to
happen through the land grant
universities or through politicians or
through
big gag big food I I can give you a long
list of people or entities it will not
include if it happens it's going to be
call Consumers drive it and and sadly
it's got to be the it's got to be the
consumers that can afford it let me say
this be clear on this my food is not as
cheap as commodity food it's not we
don't expect it to be of course we all
those costs that are thrown out of the
commodity model absorbed in my model we
we we we I can't I can't grow uh food
the way I grow it and sell it in the
commodity Market he's got to go to a
consumer that can afford it and will
choose to afford it and I still I worry
about the people that can't afford I
worry by that but I can't I can't solve
that problem at the same time right you
you went to University studied animal
science are universities or colleges
teaching this your kind of farming model
or is it you know what industrial and
nothing else that's that's a good
question that's that's a great question
so the answer for the most part is it's
strongly influenced by the big food
companies big tech companies that that
donate money to them very strongly but
there are a few uh Michigan State
University uh has a uh is a Savory Hub
that's kind of a long story we didn't
get into but there's
a holistic manage Land Management System
Savory not like Savory food guy's name
that's what I was
wondering
doood and all I know is that you don't
want to be an unsavory Hub that's a
different good Al is a guy from South
Africa that that uh we I took my
holistic training under him in in South
Africa before you go will is this quote
attributed to
you mother nature knows everything
forgets nothing and bats
L it AB it absolutely is it's the truest
n thing I ever said wow that's a great
great quote Mother Nature knows
everything forgets nothing and bats last
that's that's that's badass right
there that's some serious wisdom going
look what if you can look at the the
world that you operate in in that
way there's a connection it's a serious
connection yeah yeah W mission statement
and wisdom rolled into one yeah so guys
we got to call it quits there but my
gosh I'm delighted to learn uh from you
will that thank you for providing us
with authentic food we appreciate right
and that you exist in this world uh this
is an important Cog in a wheel that is
being built and slowly being turned and
maybe one day we'll look back on this
show and say oh that was he was a
Pioneer now everybody does it you know
that's kind of what we what maybe would
be nice The Arc The Arc of progress I'm
very grateful to you all for having me
on this yes thank you very much all
right you're all welcome well check out
Will's book a bold return to giving a
damn from an authentic farmer yes some
St do still exist in this world so Gary
Chuck thanks for being my co-host once
again always a pleasure Neil all right
this has been Star Talk special edition
uh all about the future of farming and
how to make it sustainable in this world
in this universe Neil deg grass Tyson
here as always bidding you to keep
looking
up
[Music]
a